you know when you have hundreds of
people making comments about your body
about like your intimate areas it does
really affect you you know everyone had
an opinion of me now suddenly it was all
very public
um and i think you internalized an awful
lot of that and i thought what everyone
said about me was true
[Music]
how much did you know about revenge porn
before it happened to you
uh i knew nothing about
uh revenge porn image by sexuals before
it happened to me
um it was very much something that i
kind of seen
talked about like in the media i say i
know there was like a few
videos of girls that went viral and
stuff and like it was honestly really
common as well
like i myself was in group chats where
like a girl's new to be shared in and
everyone kind of thought it was funny
because no one was properly educated
honest it was sent to my grandparents it
was sent to my parents it was sent to my
whole family
and
it was also every time i went on social
media it was just being shared like
hundreds of times i was getting hundreds
of text messages off my friends off
everyone it's so common and so
normalized especially in like schools
and like younger circles that i didn't
really realize there was anything wrong
with it
when it got shared it blew up overnight
nearly viral like everyone had facebook
statuses i had 400 plus messages on
facebook calling me every name under the
sun telling me
to take my own life
anything you can think of slush
anything you can think of it was really
really really bad it was shared like
thousands of times i had girls uploading
it as their facebook profile picture
putting up statuses about me
it was really really bad when it did get
out
and the person
that shared it out i have an idea who it
was who started it but i obviously can't
prove anything which makes it very
difficult because there's nothing really
i can do about it in that instance
why do you think that man published that
we do
um so he was really
not good to me he was quite abusive i
think i think i can't say
who did who published it obviously but
um the person i suspect who did it was
really bad and quite abusive and went on
to stalk me for many years i have a
restraining order and everything and i
think it was very much if i can't have
you
no one else is going to want you and
just completely tried to destroy me um
there was threats there was death
threats for years
um
so i think it was just very much a
it was just a malicious thing to do it
was just to get at me
so when the video got out did you
contact police what did you do uh when
the video got out no i didn't contact
police because i kind of looked it up
and it wasn't a crime in ireland at the
time so there was nothing that really
could be done about it um like there was
one night he was trying to break into my
house so he was outside my house and i
called them and they were like oh let us
know well let us know if he breaks in
and i was like
well that's great you know so there was
no help there was there was nothing i
could do um i was off social media
completely kind of went underground and
speak to anybody
um for a long time you know i wasn't
even really a member of society i was
just i was in a very bad place for
a long time because of it
would you say it affected your mental
health oh but like very much so it
completely changed my life
um how i viewed myself
you know when you have hundreds of
people making comments about your body
about like your intimate areas it does
really affect you you know everyone had
an opinion of me now suddenly it was all
very public
um and i think you internalized an awful
lot of that i do think impacted my sex
life as well because i was a lot more
confident before
those videos got released but then of
course i had
hundreds of people commenting on my body
so all of a sudden i was insecure by
things that i didn't even know i should
have been insecure about her like people
had perceptions of me that i didn't even
have myself before that and then of
course when you tried to have sex after
that you're kind of like just hearing
everything everyone said online in your
head going around in a circle
i went to therapy and there was a lot of
me reframing it in my own mind to say
um this isn't something that i did i
didn't really actually do anything wrong
this is like a societal issue
um this is something that was done to me
to harm me and then just saying like all
these people are trying to tear me down
i was like i can't let them win
what was the thing that helped you turn
your life around and get over this
um i think the turning point for me was
when i kind of saw so many people going
through it
i realized that like people were
actually starting to reach out to me
about their own instances because
obviously mine had been so public and i
kind of spoke about it a little bit
there's so many people impacted by this
and i was like i don't think anything
any one of them did anything wrong so
why am i putting that on myself and why
am i saying that i completely ruined my
own life
um i think that that was kind of the
turning point to seeing how many victims
there was and how many people i knew
personally have been through it i made a
petition because i said the first thing
that's really important in all this is
education um
you know if people don't know about it
they're not going to be able to help
much i don't think people realize like
the scope of it so
by making the petition it kind of blew
up overnight and then i was doing like
radio and um
all of that and then it brought a lot of
awareness to it
so
the law that was being proposed as well
was failing and i knew that the one in
the uk had failed because in the uk you
have to prove intent to cause harm and
that's on the victim and i was like the
law that they're currently going to pass
just won't be good enough and will
cause it to fail so i met up with people
um i knew and we drafted kind of like a
an idea of a law that would work and it
included like threatening to send images
and all the other stuff now it didn't
pass exactly how we would have wanted it
to but we knew like it was probably
better to pass it now because there's so
many people that go through it when i
created the petition i used the words
revenge porn just because it was such a
commonly known one but i refer to it
image-based sexual abuse because it's so
harmful to call it revenge porn and it
puts the onus on the victim of the crime
um that they have done something wrong
to deserve this that it's a revenge when
really it's just it is a form of sexual
abuse
so when was the law passed
so christmas 2020 i think it was the law
was passed and it came into effect in
that february but it's only been passed
for a year i think officially a year in
like a few months
um i think it has been used in a few
cases but i don't think it's nearly
strong enough still
as a law and it's still not being taken
seriously because even the guards
themselves have no education on this
matter so they don't know how to handle
it properly i still have people going in
being told that there is no law so
there's still a lot of work to be done
to tackle it i think it really starts
education
young
all throughout school but the thing is
is that you need education and social
media and the internet and sex because
that's still not something i think
that's talked about a lot and there's a
lot in that you have like child sex
trafficking grooming everything you
don't realize how
much of a broad issue it is and the fact
that kids aren't being taught how to
navigate the internet when it is can be
very dangerous i think is a massive
problem what's the scale of the of this
problem in the uk
um in ireland and millions of websites
each containing millions of videos
we sent uh 46 links to the guards and in
just two of those there's 245 000 images
and that's just from one website one
small thing alone so if you look at it
from a broader perspective you can
probably imagine
how bad of an issue it is and you have
all age ages you have kind of anyone
that can be impacted you've at all types
of ways like you have hidden cameras you
have
um
people filming without cons like without
consent it's just it's really really
really common
do you think you can trust people now
um no i still don't trust people and i
don't think i will be able to for a long
time i think that there's a lot of
sexual trauma that's happened to me
throughout my whole life that i think
can only really been solved by consent
education because i didn't realize a lot
of it was wrong because i wasn't
educated on consent or
when people breached that consent i had
no idea i just kind of blamed myself and
internalized everything
what would you say is the future like
for you what are your plans for the
future i would love to go into do
psychology and maybe work around image
by sexual abuse because there's not much
psychological study done around the
internet in general and i'd like to i
think i'd like to go into cyber security
as well and maybe work on making
websites safer for people
and work around consent and just do it
from a psychological standpoint rather
than
you know the way it's kind of being done
now there's a lot of religious groups
who are nearly in charge of it so i
think maybe just a fresh eyes and look
at it from more scientific perspective
if there was a young girl watching this
now who had image-based sexual assault
happen to her
what would you tell her what advice
would you give her
the one thing i always say to people is
your life's not over
you haven't done anything wrong
please don't blame yourself this is
something that was done to you and i
would say always reach out there's
multiple supports you can get if you're
watching in the uk there's a revenge
porn hotline
there's
multiple look up for your area
and go reach out for help if you can
what would you say
are the steps to protect yourself if you
want to send nudes
um
you know that you can say i can say only
send them to somebody you trust but you
don't know who you can trust and who you
can't like i'm pretty sure nearly
everyone who goes through this has sent
them to somebody they trust um what i
would say is if you're going to send
them and you're really worried about
them being shared around don't have
anything identifiable in them so tattoos
if you're
sending them in your bedroom make sure
that like there is nothing identifiable
if you're
if you want to send them i'm not going
to tell you not to do it because i don't
think that that's ever going to work you
know it's
um
and there's nothing wrong with sending
nudes as long as you're like educated
and it's something you really want to do
and you're not being pressured
um but just i'd say take precautions
that like if you don't want them getting
out or being traced back to you just
make sure that they can't be if that
makes sense
i'm going to be honest here if i could
go back and do something differently i
think that
i wouldn't have taken the nudes at all
just because of how much of an impact it
had i think i'd be a completely
different person
but also
i think that i would have reported it
at the time
and taken it more seriously is my one
thing i maybe started pushing for change
earlier but like i think when you go
through something like that it was so
different for me because i didn't know
what to do i can't blame myself for how
i handled anything at the end of the day
when did you create it only funds and
why did you do that so i made an only
fans just after i made the petition i
think um
and it was very much
two fingers up to everyone who was
sending around my nudes and i was like
you can't shame me for something if i
own it myself and obviously i was like
this is something that's used against me
if i can profit off it
then that's amazing like i've been
sexualized really badly nearly my whole
life so if i i was like maybe this is
something i can like profit from and
turning into
something good for me and honestly it
was probably the best decision i made
i guess it made me a lot more confident
because like i was so afraid when i
started it i wouldn't post anything and
then slowly assignment on i kind of got
way more confident myself and i was like
okay
this is actually something i'm
interested in doing now
um and it really like it did build
confidence because you're getting so
many compliments nearly every day now
whereas before it was like when my news
got shared it was all nearly mean
comments but now i get like
you know i get like the the good
comments now so i think it does help
your confidence well for me personally
it did anyway i kind of took ownership
in it
i was like i haven't done anything wrong
if you're going to judge me you're going
to judge me
um
but
i'm not going to judge myself
and i actually really did it made me
love myself more i think because i had
to overcome these things and decide for
myself that i was going to love myself
rather than just being oblivious
what i've been interested to see
in the last kind of
last decade i guess where social media
is the biggest it's ever been
the online
abuse and the sexual harassment is
just out of control it's completely out
of control